okay so we are covering the Joker
tie-ins for night terrors and Batman
kills himself and it's hilarious okay so
this opens up with Batman and the Joker
and the Joker's henchman on a rooftop
and Batman goes after the Joker and
slips on water cracks his face open on
the roof and then falls to his death
[Laughter]
Joker and them don't know how to handle
it like they don't know how to process
it they're like is he is he gonna fall
off and then just like smashes and it's
like I mean is this is this like one of
his jokes or is this like some kind of a
gag or like a scheme like is this part
of his plan he's just laying down there
dead or he's just he's just he's dead as
a door now take it down there like he's
his arms and legs are broken right blood
all over the place like you should you
should poke him boss just you know see
see what's up he's like I pay you to do
that you poke him right so like
literally they poke this guy and they
realize yeah man Batman's dead and
what's so crazy about this is like
Joker's life loses any sense of meaning
because of the death of Batman now for
the most part we kind of know that
because in DC Comics it's long since
been established that like Joker derives
his sense of purpose from like chasing
after Batman Batman chasing after him
right this kind of cat and mouse game
but at that point he's like all right
well I mean we can't leave him here like
grab the body and throw it in the trunk
and we'll figure out what to do and
they're like we took a train here it's
like then steal a car but like throw his
body in the trunk and then we'll figure
out what to do so following that you
pick up in a diner where Joker and his
henchmen are talking while Batman's
cadaver is just sitting there next to
the Joker which is Twisted but hilarious
at the same time I'm not gonna lie of
course they've killed everybody in the
restaurant right no Witnesses or
anything and they're just kind of like
mulling over who it is that they're
gonna kill next and initially they talk
about killing Superman right it's like
well I mean how are we supposed to kill
Superman the irony about this is that in
Injustice Gods Among Us joker well he
didn't really kill Superman but he
killed everybody who was close to
Superman which drove Superman insane but
it's not impossible to kill him right
some green Kryptonite or whatever so
they come up with a scheme right this
guy gaggy who's like the diminutive
member of the henchman team he comes
across a scheme where there's like
uranium that Joker and his guys can
steal so when they get aboard this ship
one they're all dressed as pirates which
is amazing and then two when they
realize it's just as simple as going in
there taking the uranium and leaving
even just like the challenge of of doing
this is kind of boring and it's sort of
hilarious because this just shows the
state of Gotham that it was in when
Batman was running around as a superhero
people felt relatively safe so there was
no need for like excess levels of
paramilitary forces or anything like
that to a degree it was kind of the
equivalent of folks like leaving their
doors unlocked you wouldn't necessarily
do that in Gotham but like it's that
equivalent more or less and so because
of that once they steal the uranium then
it's just kind of like I mean there
doesn't really it's just kind of like
whatever man like we'll sell it or
whatever but like the Joker's just kind
of bored right because it's just like
all these criminals are out there
committing all these crazy crimes and
Gotham but there's no Batman and so the
Joker just doesn't really know what to
do even his own henchmen bail out on him
and so once they take off he ends up
seeing this like classified ad in the
newspaper for Wayne Enterprises and he
goes there for like a job application
right he goes there like applies for a
position he gets hired on and then he
just like starts going through the Wayne
databases searching for like where's all
the money
secret weapons projects just different
things like that which I feel like it
would be hilarious if that was possible
Right like where's all the money like
level six in a giant Vault help yourself
like it would be absolutely hysterical
if that were the case but then
ultimately he's introduced to a woman
named Helen now Helen is a girl that if
you've ever worked in the corporate
environment you've probably wanted to
help her finish with all her living
somewhere along the line because she's
annoying as all get out like literally
when Joker tells her like my computer's
broken I think like I can't figure out
where all the money is and I can't find
like all the super weapons projects and
stuff like that she's like oh that's not
what we do here right like we are the
approved expense reports section for the
company like our job is to approve
reports that have already been approved
but it like annoys the heck out of the
Joker because now he's encountering what
is in effect everybody's worst nightmare
which is basically just bureaucracy
corporate bureaucracy getting anything
done
[Laughter]
so literally his job is to sit
es and approve reports that have already
been approved by somebody else that's
his job and it literally starts to drive
him insane to the point where like
there's this moment where she's like
we're more like a device to the point
where like she's trying to describe what
they do and he makes this comedy he's
like okay I get it we're like the
corporate accounting seat belt she's
like no we're like a device that makes
sure that the seat belt doesn't get
damaged a seat belt protector and he
just looks at her like really
I'm sorry guys it's one of the best it's
one of the best Joker comics that I
think I've ever seen and it even gets to
the point where like he pulls out a
knife and he's just ready to just end
this woman right like right there and so
following that you actually end up
transitioning to a point where he's
meeting with the rest of the staff right
just kind of having a bit of a break and
he's like I used to work for a calendar
Factory
but then they fired me for taking a day
off
it's a terrible joke but it's hilarious
at the same time but here's where things
start to go south so what ends up
happening is this guy Mr Goodman comes
in right he's a higher up in the company
and of course they refer to joker as
Johan that's because he's just basically
going by a fake name but when this guy
Goodman gets in he kicks everybody out
of the office and he sits down with
Joker and he's like okay I've been
looking over your end of month reports
and where Joker's like are my numbers
off it's like I don't know if it's an
issue if your numbers being off man but
there's all kinds of like insane
scribbles on here ridiculous drawings
and then you've got a drawing of me
basically being deflowered by like a dog
or a boar or something like that and
he's like I really have to ask the
question man do you have any idea what
it is that you're doing now as you guys
know Joker does not usually take kindly
to insults of any kind and so he does
exactly what you would expect the Joker
to do he grabs the microwave smashes it
over this guy's head turns it on and
kills him on the spot and then basically
just takes off the rest of the day now
what's also kind of crazy easy about
this is that when he comes back in the
next morning he's got this giant trench
coat on right he's got like this loud
speaker hooked up to him and he just
starts like rambling on to all these
people in this these endless rows of
cubicles about how they're all just
groveling worms right Crocs in a machine
that seeks to destroy them that they're
boot lickers of a capitalist state that
seeks only to exert control over them
and literally like he ends up in the
office of John D right kind of like the
top dog over here at Wayne Enterprises
and what's crazy is the Joker puts on a
gas mask he opens up his trench coat and
it's just got what looks like explosives
inside of it at the very least just
massive amounts of Joker toxin he
intends to take like the whole place
down but then he's offered the job of Mr
Goodman whom he killed and of course he
takes the offer
and so a few weeks later as he's like
going through and telling everybody like
the company's basically going belly up
right like all of our stock value user
down everything's trending in the
downward Direction it's the end of times
things are going south that you
basically have people who are kind of
laughing at the jokes that he's making
and nobody really seems to be caring
about the fact that the Joker's killing
the company so where he ends up going
out with drinks for everybody he ends up
traveling back home he puts on Real
Housewives now here's the kicker about
all this Batman's body is just a corpse
sitting in the closet of the Joker
that's really all it is it's just kind
of hanging there lingering there maybe
it's some kind of a trophy but it
actually does serve a purpose and the
reason why is this there are rumors
circulating around the city of Gotham
that Batman is back right people have
literally seen him and in fact there was
one point where he came by the office
and so the Joker is completely and
totally unaware of this fact he doesn't
know the Batman's back and if Batman's
back then how in the world do you have a
situation where Batman is basically or
at least his body is in the Joker's
closet who's masquerade rating is Batman
and so what we end up getting is this
amazing moment where these crazy
nonsensical henchmen are doing crazy
nonsensical things and the Batman pops
up right now he shows up at night just
like you would expect and he's attacking
everybody here but it's not Batman who
like disarms people right and so on and
so forth no no no this is a Batman who
kills he's like throwing batarangs into
people he kicks a guy into a fire and
lets him burn alive right the whole time
he's just laughing and carrying on now
as you can probably guess this is the
Joker The Joker Is masquerading as
Batman or is he because then he suddenly
snaps awake he just wakes up now the
crazy thing about this is he's also got
a wife and a son it's kind of nuts right
like literally he's got a whole family
and his wife's just like Johanna is
having another one of your in one of
your bad dreams it's cool right like the
sun wakes up the sun gets put back to
sleep again right that kind of thing so
then you jump to an interview that's
been being done for a position between
Mr Freeze and the Joker seemingly these
guys have never met before and the funny
thing is one of the one of the funniest
interviews ever where Joker basically
asks him and corporate speak you know
what makes you think you'd be a good fit
for the company you know what do you
think your strengths and weaknesses are
and he's like well my biggest weakness
is warmth and my biggest strength is
that I've shut myself off from
compassion empathy and other emotions
that have made the world grow weak right
so like all the angsty people on Reddit
is basically what Mr Freeze is and so
where Joker keeps calling him Mr fries
because technically it is spelled the
way you would spell fries but it is
pronounced freeze then they kind of go
back and forth a little bit you know
where it's like it's actually freeze
fries your name is spelled fries it's
pronounced fry it's like no it's spelled
fries but it's pronounced freeze and
it's like whatever man who cares right
like uh why do you want to work here
and the thing about this is that Victor
freeze and a lot of the other
traditional villains out there in Gotham
scarecrow and those guys they see the
Joker is somebody up there in a kind of
of Ivory Tower to a degree and while the
city itself is effectively falling apart
and even Batman returning is really more
of a hyper violent Batman killing and
destroying everything is one of these
situations where in a lot of ways they
kind of blame the Joker right like you
killed Batman and you're the reason why
this crazy Batman is here now killing
people and why Gotham is probably even
worse of a place than it was before
because this Batman is more effective
than he was before and so it's kind of
wild because following that moment we
actually figure out what's going on here
that joker is in the middle of sleeping
he gets up and he puts on the Batman
costume when he's masquerading as Batman
he's actually sleepwalking that's what's
going on here and I gotta be honest with
you guys it's kind of dope because as
he's doing this he ends up like running
out into the city of Gotham he ends up
coming across gaggy as former henchman
along with him having a couple of his
own henchmen and then starts like
attacking them and then gaggy realizes
it is the joker masquerading as Batman
but at the end of the day there's no
reasoning with him now what you could
argue here is Joker is actually
suffering from disassociative Identity
Disorder right the Batman Persona is a
whole different personality designed to
cope with the trauma of him killing
Batman it's messed up in a lot of ways
but hey whoever said the Joker was a guy
who was not screwed up the guy is the
definition of a broken human being right
so the thing about this is that you end
up transitioning to like a company
baseball game right Wayne Enterprises
versus lexcorp and the Joker in the
middle of all this like freaks out when
one of the guys that works for lexcorp
the second baseman makes his offhanded
joke about how Lex Luthor keeps striking
everybody out and the Joker's the only
one that seems to be able to get a hit
on the ball so they should just start
calling him Batman he literally chokes
the guy to death now something that I
want you to notice here everybody is
very Cavalier right they're very
nonchalant about the Joker killing a guy
right because remember this is all a
nightmare for him right this is night
terrors this is all taking place in his
head that's one of the things to
remember about the whole night terrors
tie it it's all going on in Joker's head
and so it's kind of just the world in
which he lives and so what ends up
happening here is that Bruce Wayne
himself who is actually the coach for
the Wayne Court team basically the guy
who runs the entirety of Wayne
Enterprises as you would expect ends up
inviting Joker over for dinner and when
they get in there of course John D's
there because John D is basically like
the Alfred stand-in in a lot of ways for
Bruce Wayne and so on and Bruce Wayne of
course asks why do you have any kind of
a shellfish allergy well Joker's like no
and I mentioned that because when they
get there basically shellfish is what's
being served now the thing about this is
that there's a comment that's made by
John D or really Winifred is the name
that he's given here where every time
Bruce Wayne eats shellfish he starts to
kind of become a little unhinged right
he sort of starts to go a little bit
nuts but there's this comment that he
makes about how he pretty much knows
that joker is nuts the Joker's going
crazy and Joker is basically becoming
Batman now the question that has to be
asked here is if Batman's dead what's
the deal here with Bruce Wayne we're not
given an answer we're not because this
is designed to take place in Joker's
head and Joker's insane and there's very
rarely any clear answer to anything it's
done in a very fast and loose and really
Cavalier way which works I think it fits
in perfectly with the nature of the
Joker's Mantra but then he suddenly
skips forward to a point where he's
giving like this meeting to everybody in
the office and all these board members
are basically Batman villains who have
been brought in by the Joker and
effectively work on the Board of
Trustees or work as as the main board
for Wayne Enterprises and there's just
like this guy named Ethan who is just
kind of a bit of a goofball so Joker
stabs him to death with a pencil and
then just kind of hasn't escorted out
the problem is that once Joker gets back
home his son has discovered Batman's
corpse in his closet so the Joker starts
pushing the courts back in and then he
tells the sun you got to forget
everything you saw uh I don't know
what's going on here it's it's just one
of this is one of these things never
come in here uh this is weird right just
just ignore what you saw not a great big
huge deal so even where the kid leaves
and his wife comes in the Joker kind of
dismisses it and says no you know I just
had a really bad day at the office and I
took it out of my son you know it's it's
that kind of a thing you know I need to
go for a walk so what he does is he
concocts this scheme because he has not
figured out that he's Batman he hasn't
connected the dots yet and so with the
scheme that he has the whole goal is to
basically trap Batman right like he
pulls together like all these resources
and he creates like a joker Toxin and
all that kind of stuff and he even like
brings together all these henchmen and
everything the kicker here is he decides
to lay down and take a nap before Batman
arrives or I guess kind of goes out into
the night the way he normally does and
of course that's when the Batman persona
takes over and when that happens he
immediately starts attacking everybody
right like just starts jumping in
attacking criminals everywhere he sees
them right and he starts making like all
these just terrible jokes at the same
time he's like did you hear about the
jogger who's afraid of speed bumps he's
slowly getting over it
I love the Joker's jokes I don't care
how corny they are they always come off
as amazing but what seems to have
happened here kind of filling in the
blanks a little bit maybe the Joker
really does seem to have figured out
that his alternate Persona is Batman
that when he's asleep he's running
around as Batman in the city of Gotham
most likely it came off the heels of the
conversation that he had with Bruce
Wayne so bringing together all these
different henchmen was designed for the
purpose of tracking himself sure like
there's the whole idea of Batman and
like they are there because it was the
Joker's plan too quote unquote catch
Batman but I'm talking about like a
subconscious level right like he wanted
to catch himself he just wasn't
consciously aware of the fact that he
was looking to capture himself right if
he's under that kind of notion that what
is it like serial killers want to be
caught which is why they broadcast their
crimes all over the place but regardless
of how you slice it all of the Joker's
forces come running in and as soon as
that happens despite the fact that
Joker's trying to fight them off as best
he can that literally they pop their
Joker toxin right his mask comes off all
of his henchmen realize he is actually
Batman even he himself realizes that
he's Batman and in these final moments
he starts screaming out and calling out
about how they can't kill Batman that
they need Batman that he needs Batman
that they all have to have Batman that
Batman has to exist right like literally
losing his mind he wakes up in the real
world right the nightmare ends he just
wakes up in the real world and he's just
kind of like well that was weird right
that was strange and he's like so
literally talking like all these
henchmen that he had fallen asleep next
to when uh the god of nightmares had
basically attacked everybody and put
them all into a dream state he's like so
that was all basically just Nightmare
and Solomon Grundy and his half-broken
English is like yeah like you're among
friends now and the Joker's like
everybody shut up man I'm gonna go back
to sleep and the story ends with that
being said guys if you want to get
caught up on night terrors make sure you
guys click the link to this playlist and
I will catch you on fighter peace